voilà alors je vais vous donner le
meilleur vous savez qu'on a
dématérialisé depuis les chocs
pétroliers
et vous savez avec quoi ça s'est fait
essentiellement avec la financiarisation
de l'économie
vous avez pas mieux comme pib
dématérialisés que les bulles
spéculatives et je vais vous donner un
exemple vous prenez un mètre carré vendu
à ajaccio vous le vendez aujourd'hui
mille vous le vendez dans 3 en 2000 le
flux physiques n'a pas changé c'est un
mètre carré et c'est toujours un mètre
carré par contre la production de
crédits si vous si vous endetter pour
acheter ce mètre carré double sas à
rentrer dans le pays dès les impôts
locaux perçus par les collectivités
locales les fameux droits de mutation au
moment de la transaction double sas à
rentrer dans le pib les commissions
d'agent ce si jamais vous avez pris une
agence pour rendre double sas à rentrer
dans le pib
donc voilà un exemple sur lequel j'ai
pas fait un gramme de flux physiques en
plus j'ai doublé ma contribution au pib
parfaitement dématérialiser les premiers
comme dématérialisation juste il ya un
petit sujet j'ai augmenté l'encours de
crédit donc ce qu'on a fait j'aurais pu
vous le montrer parce que j'ai une très
belle courbe là dessus depuis les chocs
pétroliers en fait l'énergie s'est mise
à croître moins vite que le pib mais la
dette si lisa croître beaucoup plus vite
que le pib et ça c'est vrai dans tous
les pays comme toutes les économies
occidentales
l'endettement public n'existait pas en
74 l'état en france n était pas en dtm
en 74 l'apparition de la dette date de
74 donc l'endettement public et privé a
augmenté dans toutes les économies
occidentales depuis le choc pétrolier et
à chaque fois que vous avez une tension
un peu plus forte sur l'énergie
l'endettement augmente un peu plus vite
et il a totalement explosé cet
endettement depuis 2005 c'est à dire
depuis le moment comme je voulais dit
tout à l'heure où le pétrole s'est
arrêtée de croître au niveau mondial a
commencé à décroître en europe et à ce
moment là on a fait encore plus de pib
dématérialisée qu'avant avec une
production de crédits qui a encore plus
exposés évidemment ce truc là finira par
expliquera tout ça va finir par
dégonfler oui c'est très exactement
alors à mon avis il ya que de manière
d'effacer une dette
c'est l'inflation ou le défaut donc il
va se passer l'une des deux choses
suivantes pour les gens qui ont des
obligations
je vous le dis je vous l'écris inflation
ou défaut
donc on revient un jour on vous dit il
ya 7 % de votre sicav qui vaut plus rien
vous êtes pourtant votre assurance vie
qui vaut plus rien ça c'est l'option à
mais à mon avis comme sait les riches
vieux qui ont ce genre de truc c'est
juste un transfert instantané au profit
des jeunes donc ce n'est pas
nécessairement une mauvaise chose
l'autre option c'est l'inflation bah oui
mais ils en ont bien profité
donc peut-être que finalement c'est le
juste retour des choses l'autre l'autre
l'autre effacement de dettes c'est
l'inflation
donc en gros chaque année votre truc
vous un peu moins parce que les taux
d'intérêt qu'on vous sert sont un peu
inférieures à l'inflation
ça c'est l'option japonaise par exemple
donc vous avez voilà mais à mon avis il
va se passer comment voulez vous
remboursez quelqu'un quand ce qui vous
permet de le rembourser c'est à dire le
fameux pib va décroître d'année en année
prépare
alors parlons juste pour finir là-dessus
je pense que ce qui est gravissime dans
cette histoire c'est qu'on sait qu'on
soit pas prévenues c'est-à-dire que la
paire de lunettes chaussées par
l'essentiel des épargnants ne permettent
pas de comprendre qu' on est parti dans
un système dans lequel quelque chose
doit se passer qui n'est pas favorable à
la sécurité de leur épargne mais mais
donc ça c'est emmerdant
maintenant si on comprend collectivement
où sont les arbitrages en va en
conscience celui qui est le moins
mauvais j'ai patiemment un veilleur
entreprises